好,謝謝大家,然後我覺得這兩周市場,特別這周末,市場變動挺大的
然後我update一下上一周的情況,然後其實上一周我們講到了就是整個AI的
我們叫做DP泡沫的根基在NTOPIGO OpenAI,然後我覺得今天在延伸講一下
就是在這些,在這裡面,最後Hyper Scala我覺得會是怎麼樣的定價
然後其他的會是怎麼樣的定價,接著就是我們講到可能會有的危機
然後我覺得這周在延伸講一下有可能的應對,市場最後會怎麼去反映這件事情
然後特別把政府這一層面會怎麼反映,Hyper Scala這邊會怎麼反映
然後對於我們在市場上的中的人要注意哪些,然後有些什麼樣的標的,我們可以再去看
上周時間比較緊嘛,那我給你們一個直觀的感受吧
剛才我進來的時候,正好上午生成的這個powerpoint嘛
然後這個powerpoint是用Glock一樣的4.8模型生成
然後給你們看一個,這個記得吧,這個是我們在一個月前生成,一個半月以前生成
所以你可以看到這個模型,就是肉眼可見的模型的質量下降的,下降的幅度
沒有做任何修改,這個powerpoint我還是自己改過一點
所以你可以看得到他們之間的這個模型的能力的差別
那麼這只是寫PPTL,那你在寫程序的時候,出來的bug可能是這個差距更大
所以這一個月Andobe的業績會不會下降
我一直在考慮這件事情,我覺得不太會
為什麼呢?因為我自己用了token多了好多倍
因為它變喘,所以它用了好多倍,那麼以後會不會下降
我覺得這個是個時間問題
就是現在大家沒有選擇在被,我朋友說一句話就是比較那個的,就是在被崩老頭嘛
它在用不停地讓我們用更多的token,然後其實效果我們token的質量在下降
這個事情以後會不會有變化,我覺得不好說
但是可能6月份沒有什麼,華爾街主要是看財務出去
你的業績是不是增長,你的gross是不是會變快
在什麼情況下,這個業績會變差
一方面它的模型的確質量下降的很快,不光是還走皮,我朋友也一樣
然後第二個呢,就是我覺得有可能是在那些公司在重新review你的投入和產出的時候
那現在大家沒有review這件事情,沒有回顧這個事情
現在包括像meta這些CIM嘛
他們還是要求很多的公司都是這樣
要求它員工使用到一定的token
就是有token的使用,就是一定要,就像KPI一樣
這個其實是行而上學的一件事情
我們回頭看跟當時做那個運營,其實是很相似的
在做運營的時候,大家也要用到後來發覺不對,這個成本報表了,我們要控制一下
那就是會有一個過程,都被搞歐北,我覺得就是我們會看到我們講的命嗎
那麼其實上週,我們先說上週市場吧
上週市場呢,其實我們沒有看到,我這有個vix的圖
vix的圖找不到,他們又把我畫上去
就是你們看到,如果打開那個,比如說追令view,你去看一下vix的話
vix上週其實只跑到二十幾
那相對於去年跑到四十六十,去年還跑到五十六十吧
今年年初跑到五四十幾
這種幅度的波動率的上升
我覺得相對來說還是比較可控的
也就是週五的時候,雖然半導體跌了很凶
基本上看到的名字都跌了百分之十百
整個NASDAQ指數跌了百分之四年
但是沒有看到過往這種恐慌,vix的上升
其實和整個我覺得gamma position上沒有那麼厚
就是賣出破壞的人沒有那麼厚也有關係
市場在週一的時候迅速做了一輪修復
其實特別是在存儲上面,這個修復是比較明顯
這就是我們講到之前一直在說的樓批,就是低批跑模的一個特點
就是當這個市場一旦進行回調,哪怕就回調了百分之三十
你會覺得這個市場很便宜
你會覺得,我看哪家投放我忘了
出了一個報告說HBM以後一季要到五十三塊錢
然後還要漲,然後這些公司的盈利還要跑
上一週,上一週NED在華江北的存儲
NED就是硬盤,NED硬盤漲了百分之七十五
在那個三十五季上漲百分之七十五
然後一百二十八季基本上全部斷貨
就通過一百二十八季內全市漲了百分之三十以上
所以你會看到它繼續在漲價
所以投資人還是很勇敢的會衝進去買它的股票
所以這個是低批跑模的一個很大的特點
它一回調,然後回調幅度比較大
然後我待會兒說一下為什麼回調
回調幾方面原因吧
回調幅度比較大
然後家後們就非常敢於把錢拿進去衝進去去買
所以我們不要覺得上週這種回調一旦發生
可能會出現2000年泡沫後面這種事情不太會的
哪怕這週其實是有CTA賣出的
看看他有沒有把我CTA數據寫進去
他也沒有把我CTA數據寫進去
那這週是有明確是有CTA賣出的
然後不是在這個位置吧
就是如果下跌超過百分之一點五左右
就現在這個位置往下跌百分之一點五
短期的CTA要被flip被逆轉
然後有賣出大概500到100億
所以即使這件事情都不太會對本質造成影響
就是你可以想這個市場是非常堅固的
因為它的p並不高
有很多公司p看上去很高
但是看上去高是你在bromberg上看
那個p也很高
但其實它預期定加上明年的增產
加上可能會缺貨漲價
它到了follow locking
比方說27、28年這個p都不高
包括光都不高
所以dpe泡沫裡面的就是懂這個行業的
很多人就是會越是懂這個行業
把存儲、光
然後越是懂這個行業
越是了解公司細節的人
覺得自己是技術大牛的人
就越敢衝進去
然後也會帶動很多的資金
所以這個是
我覺得這個是一個特點
那什麼時候它的金鐘罩會被打破呢
這個金鐘罩就一定要靠
那個anthropy overbend的模型
模型的增量
模型的質量
受到質疑
這兩個
兩個併發的時候
那就會產生比較嚴重的一些問題
我今天好像看已經有人說
把那個因為anthropy降致的比較厲害
然後減少它的API使用
我今天早上看到新聞
但我忘記是哪一家
然後我可以下去再去查一下
然後那個
但我覺得這個
這個月的業績可能不會特別差
再給你們回顧一下
你們看一看這兩個
這兩個bpd
這個是一個月前的
一個月前的bpd
versus
這一個月前已經有點降致了吧
inversus現在
然後為什麼畫一個taxis hold的賭局呢
就是我覺得
今天要講的一個很重要的觀點
我認為這觀點
其實我是拿來主意
從dial那裡拿來
就是
財富其實不等於錢
財富不等於錢
hyperscalar
那些四萬一五萬一個公司
四萬一萬一個公司
他們有的是財富
但他以前有財富和錢
現在有的是財富
但他沒有錢
錢是cash
cash和well
這不是優惠事情
那為什麼A股過去十年基本沒有漲
那我覺得最近可能會有一些變化
最近裡面的fundamental
本質上是有一些變化
過去十年沒有漲
漲了只有貿台
這個是
就是說我們說這一輪
這一輪AI半導體之前
漲了只有貿台
因為
貿台是賺錢的公司
就是他賺錢
他不是賺well
不是賺財富的公司
在三公銷位比較多的時候
然後在房地產泡沫的時候
就房地
這個貿台就是一直是cash
現金公司
A股所有的公司
包括房地產
它其實都要走融資的渠道
就是中國對於A股的定位
是拿來融資的
解決企業融資的一個平台
那你一直要抽血的
那美股是一個什麼狀態
美股市上全世界收稅
然後回購
發
發瘋狂的
這麼一個平台
所以他的業務是全球的
美國是全球的
然後全球最好公司
那裡上升
然後特別是大公司
Hyperscale
Mega7
為什麼一直在漲
因為這些公司其實是一直在發出瘋狂
發出回購
他的現金流是真的
現金流非常健康
那麼他中國的毛利率是很低
你不管製造演做多大規模
他毛利率很低
所以一旦毛利率低
他就需要去融資
他就是股市裡面
他的港股A股都一樣
那個科技公司
他就你表明說
你說小米
小米很牛
小米不賺錢
小米今年一塌糊塗
小米那個去年1.8億台手機
今年預期要銷量
今年才6千萬台
一塌糊塗
但不去說他
但是整體整體的那個
他的邏輯是說
我低毛利
所以我要融資
我走規模
所以我的股市不會好
然後美國呢
是我高毛利
我是傾資產
然後我走回購
我走瘋狂
我的股市就是長牛
但是呢
在AI時代
這個被改變了
就是AI的這些5個hap scale
就是說在這個德州的賭局上面
他剛剛進去的時候
只是耕耘住
或者加了一小碼
那個時候
對於這些公司兩年前三年前
這是我如果不參與AI
我整個公司可能會被淘汰
我今天參與AI花個幾百億
上千億
這是錢嗎
對我有 else
上每年
就是我們過去來看的話
他的信
他的收入就是
你要把他的很多的語音的收入
中間一部分要打個折的
因為這些收入其實是來自於
andopic open AI
andopic open AI本身是他們投的
所以我投了你一千億
然後你每年在我這裡採購一百億
那這個錢不算的
就是你整個真正的原來的cash flow
三千億到四千億
三四千億
然後
所以幾家蓋橋
那麼我拿個
每家拿個幾百億出來投
這是一個小助
很小助
然後我不做的話
我可能會完全淘汰
所以其實這個AI
POM剛剛開始的時候很健康
那麼到現在這個規模
今年要投七千五百億
明年要投一萬億
這些公司其實都沒有錢
就是現金沒有cash
沒有現金了
他當他缺少現金的時候
他就有兩個選擇
其實我們覺得這個選擇
就華爾街
你覺得他看空AI
他好像很蠢
他其實並不蠢
他看的這個事情的本質
他只是沒有看對他們的下注有多大
就是這五家是堅信AI的
絕對知道這個底牌開出來
他們是能夠用他的技術前沿
他是能夠往前跑的
所以他被迫互相之間一定要去跟住
這個我覺得是華爾街
沒有看穿的是這個點
但是華爾街看他的這個錢的賬
是看是對的
也就是如果說
Hyperscale繼續跟著去投Kapex的話
他們的股價就會受到壓力
因為你要做一件事情
把你的Wilds
把你的市值從財富要變成錢
你才能做Kapex
你不能發亞馬遜股
漂亮家給你投資吧
所以可以看到的
從去年半導體
從去年這已經半大半年了
這些Hyperscale
就是這些大雲巢
其實他的表現是不如人意的
不如指數或者不如半導體
為什麼呢
因為我們今天進入了
美股的一個新頭期
這周期就是原來收稅
全球收稅那些公司
要在頂部去兌現自己的財富
把它變成錢
然後去餵給半導體公司
整個估值體系會不太一樣
這個我最近反思一個事情
因為我之前我也非常看好Aurocross
然後我之前看好Microsoft
我覺得它的營利沒有問題
營利基礎也沒有問題
它繼續增長
但是它的增長來自於雲端的
backload的訂單
可能不一定會被市場認可
特別是在市場擔心的時候
特別是在市場擔心模型的時候
都不太會被認可
因為你雲端訂單是來自於那兩個
加一起今年到現在一千億
一千億的收入的公司
你沒有營利
然後這兩家公司營利
也不知道什麼時候
然後那個我們總體看一件事情
就是這兩家模型公司
加上Adopio
加上Gemmela
這三家模型公司就從模型層面的收入
Versus Capax
它的增速你當然很快了
你的模型的增速很快
它的這個GAP就是可持續
我們叫可持續為模表說
你一年頭一半以
你得給我一賺個兩三千億
你才能夠說我能夠投一萬億
你賺兩三千億投一萬億
這個是最基本的
也不是收入一兩三千億
是你要賺兩三千億
然後這個才最基本
這個我們叫做這個GAP
這個分歧在變大還在變小
我覺得在變大
一直在變大
現在市場是定價它會變小
所以這個才是市場的命脈和逐漸
就是這個認為它會收窄這件事情
能不能夠被兌現
我覺得有可能會被兌現
比方說三年以後可能會被兌現
但是絕對不可能是市場認為這樣
一番豐順的被兌現
所以我覺得兩個理念
就是第一個大公司現在被迫跟住
它不跟住就現在死
就是你現在不根據那個不但半導體
有出問題
你自己要死
因為你以前已經下了太大注碼
它不知道這個大王沃德州沒有
就跟玩德州是一樣的
你已經下太多注碼
你現在不可能不可能棄牌的
然後如果你跟住
那你就必須要去融資
融資分兩部分
第一個發股票
Google發了Google發800億
Google融了800億
然後傳言Mata要融250億
就是股票
然後這是一部分是股票
第二部分要融債
就是一定是股和債並行的
然後你才能夠去做這個投資
你今年資金缺口3000億
明年資金缺口5000億
你要在市場上套出這個錢
再加上模型公司
模型公司不能光靠你去
你要做CAPEX
然後你同時的話
模型公司還得給你位錢
就是你做CAPEX是為了模型公司消費
對吧
那模型公司消費
你是你之前投資的錢
他後面的錢也要不夠的
那他也得去融資
所以你就會發現整個美股市場
是進入一個大規模兌現
因為做投入的時候
他就是大規模兌現的這個過程
這個過程和中國以前是一樣的
這個大行管
我們說大資金流跟中國以前是一樣
然後以前沒有發生過這個事情
美國以前是清清此場
那麽投資到最後能夠跑出來
就一贏拘贏
跑不出來就一舉完蛋
但是呢
這個過程是他們刷出上萬億的錢
這把這個錢
把他們把Wiles把那個財富兌現了
上萬億
然後把這個Wiles變到半導體
變成半導體的盈利
所以半導體有盈利
但是不一定有固執
可能有固執
就是大家也會很怕
就是這個擔心不光是我有
所有話的人都有
就是大家會很怕
所以不一定會一直給半導體固執
你們認為的過去的增長性的固執
15為批
我看已經有人要給美光三星海利
是15為批
我覺得簡直是瘋了
就是這個是一個商品
你要給到它確實在漲價
然後你確實可以說它盈利一直在增加
但是你要給它到15為批
10倍15為批
我覺得純粹是瘋了
但是沒有關係
他們有可能會在階段性的給
也就是他平時批被壓了很低
當模型讓你感覺到這條主線命脈
他們是可以meet together
他們是可以聚合的
我的收入是
我的收入和我的盈利
我的盈利收入是可以追上kipax
就一下子給你一個增長物質
那就會很高
因為你確實在盈利
我看到你如果進入半導體行業
我認識不少半導體行業很自身的人
然後你如果進入半導體這個行業
你每一個人有發覺全部樂觀到發瘋
我的訂單都已經滿了
我的那個一個光照的成本就翻了一倍了
我加工成本翻了一倍了
然後我一年的就這些話
我一年收入可以把一個廠偷出來
這都是這樣
但是要清晰的認識到
我們的基座是在這個東西上
在這兩個東西上
在於這些公司會持續的去奶
因為沒有辦法
他們不奶
這兩三年是肯定
就是你是需要大量的算力
讓你的模型同樣的模型更先進的模型
那跑的不要這麼爛
這這個是過去的
這個是現在不要跑那麼爛
那麼一個implication
就是它的股市是需要不停的融資
兌現財富
在這個股市的現在在高點
在這高點
要持續的大規模兌現財富
下一周
Enthalpyx要去上市
75billion
然後接著有
就說Enthalpyx已經低交材料
我不知道
然後我聽說有產業
然後Enthalpyx要去融
OpenAir要去融
然後這些傢伙都要融
就是這幾個hyperscale
幾百萬多
他就給我寫錯了
然後融股票還要融債權
所以你可以想
原來所有的hyperscale的CDS
在什麼水平
Macrosoft的CDS在零
就是幾乎是零
就是flat跟銀行是一樣
因為他們原來是金資產
現金流很足
然後可預測性很強
然後沒有任何問題
對吧
現金的cash cow
那過去他們CDS都很低
那麼我覺得中間有
現在有一個很重要的交易
其實我自己在自己做的一個交易
就是你可以去買半導體
因為半導體它是獲得現金的
雖然它不一定獲得估值
但它大概就會獲得現金
一萬億的錢裡面
老黃都能分一半
一半不到
就黃人勳動都翻一半不到
然後他再分下去
給每一季的供貨上
就是大家都很想
很多的現金收入都很高
存儲是一個很重要的部分
然後那個
有人說存儲要漲到52
我剛剛講的就是
比方說52塊錢一季
比方說那個NAT也漲很高
那麼他們其實都在真心白眼的賺錢
但是它不一定有估值的時候
它再好的時候可能會有估值
所以在股票的投入
你在Aquity的倉位裡面
應該是放在半導體裡面
你放在半導體外面全在融資
就是特別是大公司
全部在融資
所以都不大安全
我之前對歐羅波是非常看好
然後我其實
現在有一點點hazitate
有一點點猶豫的
就是它雖然過去的CAPEX
卻是要在這個季度
或者後面幾個季度兌現
這是最主要的邏輯
因為CAPEX說了它就能夠引力
所以它引力數據肯定很好看
但是引力數據好看
後面它會不會要融資
就是融資是都是要往下打的
這個和比方說金圓廠這些不太一樣
因為金圓廠半導體裡面要看
就是說金圓廠投入時間會比較長
比方說它過去幾年投過的
已經有產能的
然後它現在只要兌現使用產能
哪怕我的產能很弱
就是我原來不賺錢
比方說原來我做那個地段
就不要地段
就成熟製產
成熟製產
比方說我做CMOS芯片的
那個電控芯片現在800幅一下來
馬上就需求非常非常大
所以這些其實是相對來說更好的要點
就是你現在已有產能的這些公司
但是你要去融資的像歐羅克的
像Microsoft的那些雖然引力好
但是它整體會受到壓力
我覺得一個剛剛說過了
就是一個我覺得很重要的一個交易
是買CDS
就是買這些公司
大家現在還沒有認為這些公司的信用
會出現任何問題
不是說它要破產
買信用保險的問題
是你的信用保險機場會變寬
因為你在不停的融資
你的供應在變大
你的債券的spread
就是債券的那個CDS的這個spread
或者說你的那個融資的成本
就應該變寬
不是說你一定會破產
當然如果發生危機
有可能會把
比方說Amazon定價成歐羅克
我覺得也很正常
歐羅克以前也很低
然後一下子不要到500多
CDS是槓桿非常非常高
然後是一個槓桿非常非常高
可以去對沖風險的一個
對沖極端風險
然後其實你的Ritz explosion
你的風險長口
並沒有那麼大的一個很好的交易
所以我今天講了很長的時間
沒有講到市場
講一下延續也上上週我們講的東西
然後講一下我現在覺得一個吹來的
就是在這些裡面
找一個先進路最差的就是歐羅克
不是先進路最差的就是Amazon
歐羅克是先進路最差
但是它CDS已經很高
它到500個點
但是Amazon才30到40個點
我進去的時候30幾個點
所以30幾個點
我買了30幾個點
一年付30個點
你買了100萬股票
你買1000萬的CDS
也就是付30%一年
這個可以讓你更敢去拿半導體的倉位
真的發生大的風險
它是要幾十倍
幾十倍的長大
這個CDS
就是我們在08年
可是看到過這種事情發生的
當年Lemon Brother的CDS幾乎是很便宜很便宜
但發生問題的時候是完全不一樣的故事
但我不覺得會發生這麼嚴重的問題
我只是覺得CDS會變寬
一旦發生比較市場比較驚慌的事情的時候
它會變得更寬
那這個時候可以讓你套現
讓你可以敢去買半導體的股票
因為半導體股票
最大的風險
它就是這兩個模型的問題
說整個系統性的問題
它在單個股票和單個SACTA裡面
是沒有任何毛病的
因為它的盈利就是很好
你要融
你要把財富兌現1萬億
然後把它變成現金給到半導體
它們不會太差
就業績肯定是不會太差
然後說一下上週五
為什麼跌得這麼兇
上週五跌得兇
我覺得有三方面原因
第一個是週四的時候
我拔過的業績沒有超過預期太多
就是這樣
它肯定是超過的賣方的預期
但是它沒有超過買方預期
這個是中間的一個比較重要的原因
但是經濟次沒有跌太多
因為市場很快消化了
認為是谷歌這些人要去做開Pax
這個原因是谷歌這些以後要做開Pax
他們原來非常手很寬的
因為我只要東西做好就行
它意識到了在新時代
我是一個工廠模式
我既然要種頭路變成工廠
那我就要算成本
所以我算成本
你那個博康
你把我每年給我賺這麼高的毛利
你壓一壓
我覺得博康的guidance
它的這個元期其實納入了
其實現在大家越來越緊
花錢的時候手越來越緊
所以你在越是卡脖子裡方
你表示光存儲
那方卡脖子
MLCC那些卡脖子
它可能沒有一家能力
就買方沒有一家能力
你不可能說一個它的算力中心
因為幾張CMOS芯片那個電控不行
然後你運營不了吧
所以這個它沒有一家能力
但是它對整個總包商幫你做設計的
它有一點一家能力
所以這個就是博康的一個問題
但星期四沒有發酵太多
星期五出來那個Valrubin的事情
把市場嚇到了
就是Valrubin說少用HBM
然後這個事情我覺得根本
這不是一個特別大的問題吧
它少用HBM
第一個就是它可以更加穩定的出過
出更多的那個MV72 link
因為現在能出多少
它的限制在HBM不夠
所以它比方說在Train用的時候
要用很多的那個HBM
在infra的時候
沒有需要用那麼多
它優化一下
第二確實是買不到
買不到
那我沒有辦法高配
那我就低配
你想蘋果的
現在我手上有的一個蘋果Max Studio
是512級
現在好像也買不到了
現在已經不出512級的Max Studio了
所以像這個事情
其實並不能說明需求減少
但是在整個半導體的倉位裡面
那個槓桿非常高
就Labge ETF非常非常高
你可以看一下
就是我有個數據
就是在臺灣和南韓
就是韓國
它的總的那個槓桿ETF
增加了4.9倍
增長了5倍
包括7709
包括就是在那
它標的
只要是韓國和South Korea
然後65個別人USD
就是650億美金
然後在美國有1800億
我今天可能脫堂多說一句
美國1800多億
然後整個ETF
其實你槓桿ETF的邏輯
是你漲的時候
你就買更多
所以它一直滾進去
把它買了漲很風
然後跌的時候
它們就賣出
所以跌得賣出的
就叫我們叫Rebalance
配合著本身系統裡面
有很多的槓桿
就是韓國的存儲
存儲槓位為什麼髒
就是很多韓國人
然後這個槓位裡面
大量的槓桿
所以你這兩件事情
是配合和有可能會一起出來
所以星期五的時候
被下了一下
被英文拿的事情下了一下
加上前面有八個事情
然後加上我覺得市場
終於忽然意識到宏觀
宏觀Steal matters
因為能蓬佩洛數據非常好
所以Cabinwash能不能降息
向川普給他的任務
我覺得比較難
Wall Street General寫了一篇文章
這個title寫的比較諷刺
他說Cabinwash job just got a lot complicated
這個是我抄了Wall Street General的這個title
還是它是這麼說的
就確實他可能川普希望他去降息
他本身也是自己人
整一個AI
其實把美國的戰略也綁上了
把川普把GOP也綁上了
把Hyperscale把幾個大雲廠全綁上
大掌櫃是你卻放錢啊
然後我覺得現在非常難
這個星期要關注的就CPS數字
所以整個三方面原因吧
就是能蓬佩洛數據比較好
外國的業績
然後加上N英偉大鬼故事
其實沒有改變任何Foundamental
沒有任何改變任何基本面
所以市場進入了一個星期五
進入一個deliberate去槓桿
我們觀察一下韓國今天會不會繼續去槓桿
因為昨天晚上美國存儲反彈是蠻兇的
如果沒有辦法去槓桿
那差不多到此為止
所以它的金鐘兆很強
你看這個市場金鐘兆很強
一旦發生任何負面的東西
包括昨天歐那個伊朗這裡飛導彈
伊朗和以色列飛導彈
但是市場總是能夠很快的在你下跌的時候
給你賣回來
這個就是你PED
看上去PED的這個結果
模型不出問題的情況下
模型出問題
一切進化水月
然後這一周我就說一下
那個宏觀上兩個事情
第一個呢
這周的那個N出CPI
CPI很有可能核心CPI不會太差
就是上一次核心CPI差
因為房租的數據
我上次講過
房租數據被延後了
所以它是有一個調整在那個裡面
但是這一次CPI
我感覺核心數據不會太差
Handline CPI是不會好的
因為Handline CPI就是純CPI是因為油價
所以油價這個
但是它傳遞到核心會比較慢
然後Cabin現在Cabin Watch以後
看核心CPI中間的中間值
我們到時候看它看什麼值
看中間值
中間值可能會更加低一點
所以它會面臨一個看上去很高的CPI
它非常想降息
但是不容易
但是我覺得Cabin不會比像市場預期的這麼陰
現在市場預期是今年肯定不會降息
甚至可能會生息
生息我就不會了
但是最終這些hiperscale
我們就會說最終的方向
他們其實是需要美國政府去支持
就是在AI上
其實是美國和中國兩強在打冷戰
那麼這個冷戰裡面的
其實是需要hiperscale之外
就是這幾個暈場之外的力量
那就帶動它
然後其他我覺得就差不多
然後最後一個是CTA
CTA我剛剛講過
CTA如果再往下跌1個點到1.5個點
短期CTA會被flip
意味著就是會match大概100億
51到100億
所以這個是要密切觀察的
就是在現在這個位置上面
我覺得周一的反彈其實是比較脾弱的
雖然幅度很大
這兩說存儲上幅度很大
但總體是比較脾弱的
如果說這個周市場還是懲戒很大
因為畢竟後面還有SpaceX
抽那麼多錢去做IPO
如果說是這樣的情況下的話
可能會有賣牙
這周不出來的話
下周CTA可能也會出來
這個是資金面的一個情況
但是更加很關
我覺得我前面就是分享了
就是hiperscale和大輪轉
從hiperscale的套現財富
把這個財富變成錢給到半導體
好吧
謝謝大家的時間
我覺得你們有沒有什麼問題
然後我們可以cannain一下